your career is over Miss America so of
me I feel like this new movie of yours
is so much fun and it's something that
we need right now it's called feel the
beats how much fun was it to shoot and
is that you doing all that dancing
please I truly had the time of my life
shooting this movie and really a really
special and emotional experience for me
I think because I started dancing when I
was 3 years old
that April story is is something that's
so close to my heart everything that she
felt I felt in moments in my life so it
was just something kind of very raw and
vulnerable so it was so cool to get back
into the physicality and and the I guess
the emotional aspect of being a
professional dancer and how demanding
that is emotion it was a challenge in in
many ways but it was them an exciting
one you said that you really related to
april's story and at the beginning of
this movie she blows this major audition
in your real life have you ever gone out
for a part and just a you blew the
audition or you didn't get something
that you really wanted I think that's
the story of every eminent performer
right and that's the beauty because
anyone who's ever had a dream of making
it in Hollywood or and or in Broadway
you get met with mainly nose mainly
heartbreaking disappointments or that
audition that you just breaks your heart
because you know that you do it so yeah
obviously I mean luckily I haven't had
as big as of a of a breakdown position
that was made really bad but I
definitely had those moments and and
they're difficult but you have to learn
to stride but to make the world a better
place
we have to do it face to face not to
bring the mood down but I do want to ask
you July 6 marked the first anniversary
of Cameron voices death anything you
want to say just to continue his legacy
to honor that legacy as we approach that
date I was in Toronto the day that we
lost cam prepping to this movie and I'll
never forget that day and I remember all
of us were just overwhelmed in thinking
that he was just the happiest most
beautiful soul and that no matter what
his soul will live on forever in his
legacy because he's loved by so many and
had the most selfless heart and his
legacy is living on in the Cameron boys
foundation wielding peace that his
family is so courageously and so
beautifully pouring their hearts into
you so I urge anyone who's watching and
anyone who loved cam like we all day to
continue their legacy not only by
supporting the foundation but by being
like cam and that's just being someone
who loves first and foremost and doesn't
judge and just is like kindness walking
yeah is there a memory that you want to
share right now of him something that is
always in the forefront of your mind and
you feel like the world should know
where or can know about oh my gosh
there's too many to to put into words
there's just it was more so feeling that
cam gave when he was around you and I
think his sister put it so beautifully
but he was sunshine wearing shoes and
that's exactly who he is
I just got chills I know it would be
hard without him but I did talk to Dov
earlier this year and she did not rule
out the possibility of more descendants
even though it would be hard without
Cameron where do you stand on that front
it's tough you know it's tough to
imagine the world of disbanding
without cam for me anything is possible
because it's such a beloved franchise
but it's just it wouldn't be the same I
also do want to talk to you about the
black lives matter movement because
you've been so vocal on social media why
is that being important for you to use
your platform for that and is there a
message that you want to send to your
fans right now you know how can we not
use their voices right now our voice is
who we are and our vote is our voice so
to anyone watching our hope depends on
our vote and all of us coming to bed
together and using our voices and
fighting for justice fight for what's
right fight for our brothers and sisters
and most importantly take your voice to
the polls there does that continue right
now
[Music]